so did you figure out what caused the
error hopefully you discover that it was
this one the first query orders by name
and then you added the inequality filter
for max attendees so the first sort
order is named but it should really be
max attendees because that's where we
have the inequality filter composite
index not existing might be a problem
that you run into but it isn't the
problem this time unless you deployed
straight to app support in which case
you've got a couple of different errors
going on and again this is a problem you
might run into if you tried to fill to
say on max attendees greater than 100
and seats available less than 10 because
then you'd be using inequality filters
on two different properties in a single
query but in this case this particular
error should not be the problem we're
only using an inequality filter on a
single property so here's the error in
the api's Explorer you see it tells us
exactly what the problem is first sought
property must be the same as property to
which the inequality filter is applied
in your query the first sort property is
named but the inequality filter is on
max attendees so when you get these
kinds of errors or when you get any
errors don't be frightened by them just
go ahead and read them there's valuable
information in the errors that will
pinpoint the problems and help you fix
them